[Music]
The hail has stopped, Cocoa! It
expanded so the timing of the guard was
sloppy.
Tan
is a calculating child from the sand clone.
[Music]
After all, it's only a body after all. What
should I do?  You can't get
caught at nano speed. What you're
going to do is
unique.
Think of vinegar as speeding up. [Music] That's it. Watcher. Yeah, yeah. Smoke again. You're right there. [Applause] I thought it was movement.
That's it.  Yes, shush.Did
this guy do something by mixing it with the vinegar that his father left behind
?There was
gold dust hidden in the sand clone that he sold earlier.Using the
heat of this guy, he melted the gold.
And gold is 20 times heavier than water. That's
why it's slow. That's why they
made it so easily with sand.
Why didn't it explode? The
cold sand mixed with the hail is
hot enough to make it grow.  Bacteria with good heat conductivity play an additional role in cooling the water vapor that is released.The
last part was well done, as if it were a shadow of a language.You came up with the
lyrics well.How about doing it like this?
Hey, you're a
golden egg.